the bears
beat the buccaneers and
matt and aggie coach of the bears says
it's not always pretty it hasn't been
pretty yet at all this year but they're
four and one good morning to you our
audience on peacock and siriusxm channel
211 the dan patrick channel and nbcsn if
you're watching the rear at nine eastern
and sky sports nfl seven o'clock local
time uk and ireland and anybody anyone
who may be listening on the podcast good
morning to you peter king welcome back
how's everything
everything's going good mike you know
when i hear nick foles say you know it's
like a good old street fight in philly
and and all that you look like a
minister you've never been in a street
fight in your life
but i'll tell you that's part of the
good thing that's part of his appeal
he's a quarterback go ahead go ahead
you go ahead
i was just gonna say the good thing
about foals
at least to me
is that you have to turn on the
television and watch the game
when nick falls plays because
in the middle of the first half did you
think that nick foles was going to be
one of the heroes here i mean
you got to be kidding me
but he's just got this knack
i don't even know what it is
but he's got this knack for being really
pretty good
and sometimes great
when it's vitally important
two observations first of all wouldn't
you love to see one of these debates
whether it's
a local race a national race or anywhere
in between where there would be the
exchange we just had of you go ahead no
you go ahead that would be something if
we could just see that one time so
hopefully we're setting the example for
a member
when it comes to debate etiquette
second of all when he missed and i
believe it was alan robinson on third
and two second drive of the game wide
ass open as bruce arians would say i'm
just quoting bruce arians i'm not using
that language myself i'm just using
language that bruce arians used when he
was a commentator for one year but
anyway when whoever it was was wide ass
open sorry uh i i i said that that's
exactly why mitchell trubisky got
benched that's what nagy told me
12 days ago when he had the gut feeling
to remove trubisky from the game against
the falcons when they were down 16
points
trubisky's not getting it done on third
down and in the red zone and folz hadn't
been getting it done and then all of a
sudden he does that that is the magic of
nick foles you never know
when it's going to flip
and when it does he's smart there's an
urgency to him like let's go let's hurry
up to the line let's get another play
before it goes away let's go let's hurry
and it's you know and that's that's
what's amazing about it and also that
quality of on any given play it looks
like someone's going to hit him in the
right spot and he's going to like burst
into 20 pieces that i mean and i
obviously i mean exaggerating just 10
pieces but i mean he doesn't look like a
guy who should be out there taking that
kind of abuse but he constantly does and
he just gets up and he keeps going
you know mike i think we just buried the
lead didn't we
what's that
we buried the tom brady lead the goats
yeah that's true
yeah that's true you're right no we
found a way no we got two hours we got
two hours to get to that one i mean
let's praise the bears
let's we did bury the lead but let's
let's praise the bears because you know
i i do radio twice a week in chicago and
and they've been so confused and
ambivalent about this team they start
off 3-0 and like here's the reality when
you do that sunday thursday turnaround
you can pick up two losses just like
that and all of a sudden you know sunday
morning you're three and oh and
everything's great thursday night you're
three and two and what the hell's wrong
and i thought they were going to lose i
thought that that would be the narrative
today well the bears were you know who
we thought they were and not in the
denny green sort of way and now they're
four in one and what a different vibe
all because
they engineer a late drive and take the
lead and then they hold on in part
because the goat
well
pool to brian hoyer slash chris webber
where he he got confused he thought he
had another down so instead of trying to
get the first down on what was fourth
and five he thought it was third and
five so he threw the ball farther down
the field it was an ugly throat had no
chance of being caught and then he's
doing this hi tommy hi hi yeah he's
doing this unless he was trying to pull
some sort of jedi mind trick on the
officials that that's one of the most
stunning
absences of awareness that i've ever
seen
from an experienced smart quarterback
peter
we have do we have let's do the sound
tom brady and let's do this let's hear
let's hear from tom let's give him a
chance to defend himself
before we rip him any farther here's tom
brady
uh or bruce arians or maybe both on what
happened on that fourth down that really
was a fourth down
yeah we just said you're up against the
clock and you're up against the
uh
you know i knew we had a gain of chunks
so i should have been thinking more
first down instead of jumping on that
down
yeah i knew we needed a chunk and i was
thinking about more yardage and then uh
you know
it was just it was bad execution and we
had a great opportunity there so
just didn't uh didn't execute when we
needed to did he not know it was fourth
down
yeah he knew he knew
yeah you know what that was that was i
don't i don't want
god
again
brady
did you know it was fourth down
i got the transcript of the quotes and i
read him this morning and he was not
asked the question
did you know that was fourth down
you know and and so i st he still
i still don't know his answer to that
question
because he wasn't asked that question
so
but but again there i i mean there's a
98 chance we know the answer to the
question
but i wish he was asked the question
right you know straight out did you not
know it was fourth down or did you know
it was fourth down
but
the one thing about that play mike i
went back and watched it you know i
taped the game and i went back and
watched it
and on that specific play
he had the young running back keyshawn
vaughan
uh about three yards from
uh the first down
and he was not covered now
there was a linebacker lurking waiting
to clean up whatever there was over the
middle of the field okay
but
if brady had thrown the ball to keyshawn
vaughan who was uncovered
three yards from
you know from the first down
if he had thrown the ball to him
he i think he would have had at least an
80 chance of making the first down
and then what would have happened
they would have gone to the line of
scrimmage hustled to the line
and basically spiked the ball
and then you know uh it had whatever 25
seconds and first down to get the ball
maybe 15 yards further down the field to
get into field goal range for suck up
but obviously
and you know the the decisions he made
on all three of the throws
uh
his three last throws none of them were
very good
uh and none of them were very close
quite honestly except the one that
clanged off gronk's hands
but it just was a very very ugly final
series for somebody who should be used
to shining in those final series
yeah you know you make a great point
peter because when the bears mismanaged
the clock
on their final drive
that allowed tom brady to have a minute
and 17 seconds actually a minute and 13
seconds 73 seconds on the clock to try
to go down and get the game-winning
field goal or at least set up the
game-winning field goal from ryan sucka
everyone was like uh-oh now you've done
it bears now now by throwing the ball on
second down and not
taking more time off the clock
now you've really screwed it up
and there was just this anticipation
that it was inevitable because we've
seen it before but you know i i i think
that
one thing that we need to remember
and the narrative has always been with
tom brady at least over the past 10
years that if you can get pressure up
the middle and hit him early and hit him
often that rattles him for the rest of
the game well last night was an occasion
where they were getting the pressure
around the edges khalil mack was khalil
mack the khalil mack that arrived in
chicago two years ago on that labor day
weekend trade with the raiders
and
that was the first thing i thought of
well yeah they got 73 seconds left for
this final drive but is anyone going to
block the bears because it's pointless
to think you're going to get down the
field if these guys are going to tee off
and he did a good job of not getting hit
on that last drive but maybe
that
potential for getting hit potential for
getting sacked and the clock keeps
running rushed him to make throws before
he was ready to do it and that again is
the benefit and that's maybe the only
way to crack the code on tom brady you
got to hit him enough early in the game
so when the game's on the line he's
jittery and he's rushed because he's
concerned that here it comes again
he should be concerned last night
because donovan smith and tristan worfs
were awful
they were awful
you know
you don't
you know the bucks think
and as somebody who's covered this team
quite a bit in the last six months
the bucks
have thought
that
they had their tackle problems solved
when they drafted tristan worse
well you know to me these guys look like
they played like undrafted free agents
last night
and uh and and look at one point
brady got i think it was he got he got
hit by uh by mack on one of his sacks
and you could see
he looked up at donovan smith like
can can you give me anything here can
you can you at least deflect them it was
on the sack that that mac made where he
ran inside and i i don't know i don't
think he was even touched by donovan
smith
and brady just took the olay sack you
know because he wasn't going to be able
to get out of the way
and and look
look
that last drive
you got to pin
you got to pin the blame on brady you
just do
but i could see why
he was uncomfortable last night because
his tackles made it uncomfortable for
him
yeah and after worfs just four days
earlier had handled joey bosa that's
what made it even more stunning that
that they failed the way they did they
rang up 38 points against the chargers
defense even without durwin james still
a very good defense and it felt like the
the buccaneers were going to be able to
get it done they were moving the ball
well in the first half they were up
those two touchdowns from the bears late
in the first half made the game a hell
of a lot more interesting than i thought
it was going to be but i was expecting
shootout in the second half but both
defenses really clamped down and you
know it was field goal field goal field
goal field goal and and there was that
that drive when at one point what was it
first in 34 or second and 50. it was
just it was obscene with all the
penalties and that was when we saw the
old school tom brady
blowing a gasket and yelling it looked
like it's senator ryan jensen who took a
really stupid 15-yard penalty you know
that offensive line of the bucks has
been very chippy this year and you can't
just walk up to a guy and headbutt him
and expect there to be no consequence
that's what jensen did and you could see
brady was livid after that drive peter
and you know and well he should have
been i mean
mike
there will be teams
this week that play a game
in the nfl
and do not get flagged five times for 40
yards
the tampa bay buccaneers
you know in an eighth place in an eight
place sequence or seven play sequence
excuse me
got flagged for five penalties for a
total of 40 yards and i'm i'm not
including the one that was uh
that was declined or i think it was
offset it was offset
um so
that is why in my opinion you know if
i'm if i'm aryans
uh and look after an emotional game like
that you probably don't want to go bat
crap on your team
but
when they sit down and watch the t tape
bruce arians has to read his team the
riot act because
they handed that game to the chicago
bears handed it to him silver platter
biggest cliche ever find me any other
one and i'll give it to you but
they blew that game period
11 penalties for 109 yards for the
buccaneers 6 for 66
by the bears and i thought this was the
year that the officials weren't going to
throw a lot of flags i thought they were
only calling clear and obvious fouls i
wonder how much of this is a reaction to
maybe teams taking advantage
of the willingness or lack thereof of
the officials to throw flags and maybe
the officials are now having to
re-establish themselves a little bit
because maybe there is a lot of clear
and obvious stuff as teams try to test
the limits of of when that flag comes
out peter
and you know mike look
every single year the officials say it
isn't true it's true
every single year
there is if you look at a game in week
two it's officiated different than a
game in week 12
because the officials
open up the season officiating with
certain points of emphases
emphasis rather
and
as the year goes on
they recalibrate as the as the year goes
on you get different messages
from the officiating department in new
york and i'm sure
based on a couple of the holding calls
last night were
unbelievably ticky tech you know uh
i'm trying to remember which one but a
couple of them were just they were awful
they were terrible calls now
most of the calls that they made in the
game are legit because both these teams
are chippy
but i can tell you that
that
that this struck me
the nfl has made the line of demarcation
unofficiating
and uh last night
was a different
the game was officiated differently
yeah i agree with you completely you
know back to a point you made earlier
because i'm fascinated by why tom brady
wasn't asked specifically if he knew it
was fourth down and i think sometimes
what happens is
the media covering a given team
sometimes is so smitten with a coach or
a player that they don't no one in the
group wants to be the one who asks the
question that could maybe piss off the
person but i'm looking at the transcript
i got sometimes i think what happens is
sometimes and i want to go back and
watch the video and i think we both
should to get the question and the
answer sometimes there's a little
creative adjustment
of the characterization of the question
to take some of the sting out of the
situation by
a a a droit
uh pr staff that doesn't want that to be
the talking point all day long that does
want that lead to be buried not just for
a couple of minutes but for the whole
show and beyond but i'm gonna be curious
to watch the video
full question answer to see exactly what
he was asked because it had to be asked
look you're tom brady you've decided to
keep playing at age 43
and to to in in the critical moment of
the game the most important moment
it doesn't matter what happened before
you're down to one play it's fourth and
five keep the drive alive and if your
reaction to that is to seek out the
official and say isn't it fourth down my
god what an admission that is as to the
laps that you had in that moment you
can't say it was the crowd was too loud
that's for damn sure you can't say you
got confused you know and i don't know
what kind of communication is going on
in the helmet to tom brady my guess is
the tampa bay sideline
probably doesn't think tom brady needs a
reminder that it's fourth down and there
wasn't a spike there that would cause
you to lose track troy aikman tried to
throw him a lifeline and say well you
know when you clock it once you forget
well yeah you're right but he didn't
clock it there wasn't a spike on that
drive he had four cracks at it from
first and ten and he just
he just had a mental lapse which is
jarring be even more jarring because
it's him
yeah and mike i think maybe what the
bucks do going forward
is they basically now in situations like
this
um i mean if i were airings if i were
buying
top it's fourth down
it's
it's fourth down
right you gotta you gotta say something
in the guy's helmet to make absolutely
sure because i mean look
most teams you know your helmet is live
until 15 seconds on the play clock
so that is more than enough time to both
give the play and say hey third down now
third down or whatever
you've got plenty of time to do it so i
mean obviously it's going to be a bitter
lesson learned and you know what i
thought at the end of the game last
night mike i kept thinking to myself
okay
we don't really know who the saints are
right now
but we think we know that when they get
michael thomas back they're probably
gonna be
at least as good or better than tampa
bay okay
and that was a game last night
that could be the difference between
getting a home game in the playoffs and
getting a road game you know having to
go all on the road
um you know to be a super bowl team
and so
you know look you don't want to make too
much of it and hey the bucks have their
share of injuries too they're throwing
the guys that nobody in america has
heard of all through the game last night
but
uh i do think the saints when they get
michael thomas back
and are in and now with traequan smith
being you know emerging as a real
legitimate weapon for them
they're going to be i think they're
going to be the saints again
there's the saints buccaneers rematch
looming on sunday night football later
in the year as well and that could have
major ramifications especially with the
buccaneers after those three straight
wins and looking like everything was
falling together last night things were
falling apart and i had a i had a vision
there
and you know i quit being a baseball fan
in 1992 when the pirates blew the nlcs
to the braves in game seven but one of
the things i remember distinctly about
watching baseball playing some baseball
not very well in my younger days there's
always communication among the fielders
as to how many outs there are there
always is always it's routine right the
infielders tell the outfielders one out
to uh and i i just have this image now
of everyone on the buccaneers telling
tom when it's fourth down the center the
tackle the tight end the running back to
the point where he gets pissed off about
that
i think i get the point i mean that's
what i'm hoping for uh because look you
look that that moment
we don't know how it would have gone
right but if he had known it was fourth
down he tries to get the first down he
gets the first down the game's extended
we don't know what would have happened
maybe they'd have won the game maybe the
narrative today is tom brady pulls it
out somehow and they're four and one and
the bears are who we thought they were
but now the bears are four and one and
the bucks are three and two and both
teams are in divisions where they have
an elite franchise that they're
contending with and the bears are trying
to catch the packers and the bucks now
have to stave off the saints who already
have beaten them once it's just it was
an incredible way to win you know it
wasn't one of the high scoring games
that we've gotten used to 34 31 38 35 it
was 20 to 19 kind of feels old school to
have one of the teams in the teens but
but man it was a compelling ending uh
especially because of the whole brady
angle and and also foals i mean look
it's the super bowl 52 reunion it was
brady's chance to stick it to falls and
falls stuck at the brady
i think what tom brady will do i bet he
did it on the plane on the way back to
tampa last night i bet he watched the
tape and i bet he saw keyshawn vaughn
wide open about three or four yards from
the sticks
and he's got to be thinking
i could have had the ball 12 yards from
field goal range with 25 seconds to go
uh second down clock stopped
you know he could have had two downs
basically to get them in final field
goal range
and i will bet a lot of money if not
last night sometime today he'll watch
that and he'll say
man i really really cost us last night
yeah um i i i
i agree with you completely and you
wonder what it's going to spark for tom
brady going forward he was already
determined he was already
lets bleeping go all the time
does this push him if it's even possible
to a higher level of determination
remember after week one when he got
called out by bruce aaron's a couple of
times one of the reports one of the
sunday splash reports was he's even more
determined and focused or whatever it
did it implied that he wasn't already
well he already was and he found a way
to become more determined after week one
if it's even possible if it's if 130 is
possible that's going to be the tom
brady determination level going forward
after what happened last night it was
his first nationally televised game as a
member of the buccaneers at prime time
but he's had two games that were
televised on big platforms week one late
afternoon and then week five prime time
he lost both of them he didn't look
particularly good in either of them and
he's keenly aware that the ratings are
off the charts in boston
for these games he's human he gets it
it's got to drive him crazy peter he's
on these big platforms
and and he's not showing he can thrive
without bill belichick and
chances are
if that was a patriots game last night
bill belichick josh mcdaniels would have
made damn sure that tom brady knew it
was fourth down which gets back to the
whole
who
who is it right who is it
which which is it is it the coach is it
the quarterback so uh i uh
and and matt casey makes a good point
they didn't let hoyer know he was out of
timeouts on monday night so i don't know
i don't know i don't know who gets who
gets the blame or the credit but but
isn't that great the perfect book end
monday thursday brian hoyer makes it a
horrific mental lapse on monday night
that could have been avoided by the
coaching staff tom brady makes a
horrific mental lapse on thursday night
i could see brian hoyer it looked like
he was
he was looking up at the official toward
the end of the half
at the end of the first half and he was
saying was that wrong
and and you know because it was just
such a shocking decision to make
i mean how do you make that decision and
i'm sure that tom brady will be feeling
the exact same thing about how this one
ended too
and from the actual audio of the press
conference brady was asked was it clear
for you guys whether it was third or
fourth down on that last place so
the transcript as we've seen before
the transcript
creatively summarized by way of the
question posed to not make something
that was already a big deal an even
bigger deal how about this one too
before we give the bears some more props
on the way out the door for this segment
brady after the game
b-line to the locker room and my look
my first thought was hey good because
that's what we should have seen all year
long
the
covet protocols require
unenforced to this point require the
players to avoid getting within six feet
of each other we saw the photo earlier
this week of stefan gilmore who would
test positive the next morning for covet
19 in the face of patrick mahomes after
the monday night game in kansas city
i don't think brady was just being a
a conscientious practitioner of covid
hygiene i think it was
getting me the hell out of here
and uh uh just kind you know we we it's
it's fine look nick foles was out there
looking around like where the hell is
tom brady but uh it it i i think that
this wasn't tom trying to avoid getting
infected i think this was tom getting
the hell out of there while he could
if if the nfl before the season
told players that they could not do a
jersey exchange after the game if they
did that which they did
why
after what happened this week
did they not tell players and coaches
leave the field after the game
without exchanging pleasantries and hugs
and without doing the prayer circle
leave the field without doing all that
i don't understand why the nfl
did not do that this week because
absolutely unequivocally
patrick mahomes and you know doing the
doing some sort of semi-hug with with
gilmore after the game and then patrick
mahomes on wednesday
uh it was sounding like he i i didn't
see it but sounded like he apologized
for it and almost profusely
so i i mean my point is i mean what
exactly is going on with these protocols
you know if you're going to be serious
about them at the end of the game get
off the field
none of the none of the hugs you know
have have a hug by text i mean i i
i just simply do not understand
why that was not done this week that's
an opportunity lost
and there's there's a strange mixture of
optics
and science that the nfl is pushing here
because one of the things i did was i
circled back to the league and i said
whatever happened to the
restriction on being within six feet of
each other after games and they said
it's still the rule and then they sent
me quotes from cdc guidelines saying
that brief interactions don't put anyone
at risk well then why do you have the
the rule
why are you undermining your own rule
why don't you either get rid of the rule
or enforce the rule but don't undermine
your rule uh which you know confusion
about what the rules really are and what
the procedures really are it's kind of
been our life for the last seven months
as we try to figure out what this virus
is all about but i think they they know
it looks bad
they don't think it's a significant risk
of virus transmission but it does look
bad especially given everything the nfl
has been going through this year we'll
be obviously talking about that coming
up as it relates to the major surgery
the nfl has performed on the schedule
yet again
let's give the bears just a little love
on the way out though
uh nick foles as matt nagy said after
the game this is what he does right it's
not going to be dominant he's not going
to throw
seven touchdown passes although he once
did throw seven touchdown passes was it
six or seven remember when he was with
the eagles and they played the raiders
it was seven forty nine nothing he's on
the road i think it was fresh yeah
crushed the raiders that day um he's not
going to do that at this stage of his
career watch he'll do it next week he's
going to have flashes where he he gets
it done and he's more likely to get it
done
when the game's on the line he steps up
in those spots i mean you know he i
don't think he's a great practice player
and in under normal circumstances early
in the game he's not going to be a
gunslinger but when they need it when
the opportunity is there he can he can
make that big throw he stands in the
pocket the players love him and he he
led the drive that won the game period
in a game against tom brady both
quarterbacks had chances to lead
game-winning drives one did
one didn't
just like the super bowl
you know watching falls the one thing
that really occurred to me
during the course of this game is this
is the perfect team for him to be the
quarterback of right now because
the bears have a good chance most weeks
of playing low scoring games their
defense is really good their rush is
oppressive
uh khalil mack has been reborn after a
injury-plagued year last year
and so this is if you're going to play
games in the 20s
you know while so many teams in the
league
are playing games in the 30s
the chicago bears i would say are going
to play games on average in the 20s
this year
and
you like having a guy like nick foles
who is going to take care of the
football for the most part
and who when when the game is really
tight
times are tough you got to make a play
or two
he's got a good chance of making the
play
and and he's never going to have gaudy
numbers
but he's the kind of guy who i think you
want on your team
in crunch time because you trust him
you've seen him do it before
and that kalumax stat line is reduced to
writing by matt casey and the document
that we
that we use as our guidance for the show
two sacks three quarterback hits one
batted pass and one ragdoll toss of a
rookie offensive lineman that moment was
like what in the hell it was a one-armed
it was it was wwe they were showing the
wwe commercials all night long it was
fitting they should use that clip
in the further cross promotion that fox
does of its wwe properties and khalil
mack just taken tristan worfs and i mean
i think tristan worse was saying stop
the ride
stop the ride
i want to get off
[Laughter]
uh and he did it all with one arm all
right uh let's take a break as mentioned
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports